you think CBD works I on site on
inflammation I don't know it does do you
smoke a lot of weed Sasha no ever you
drink yes
a lot okay good question
trying to get her history no no I
if she's gonna be a friend of mine yeah
I'm really want to establish a real
friendship with her yeah I have to know
all the nooks and crannies of what she
is she's all about I don't want to be
friends with a drug addict okay well let
me say something I have a clear idea of
who you are as a person I have to I mean
the stamp am i approved in mine I'm
gonna give him winner their ranking as a
person no ranking systems yeah as a
human being and I'm talking about
morality ethics what you look like how
you drunk and everything everything's
gonna like count right so there we go
and when I want to end like this okay
and this is truly and I'm saying this
based on if um you know there was an
jambe apocalypse and I and I had to live
with a survive with a group of people
that I could trust and that could do the
job right build a fence also not steal
things and be honorable but also in a
zombie apocalypse I want you to look
good as well you know I mean I know
there's things that are like you know
more important I guess like nutrition
and and sleeping your safety but I want
you to look good as well so um
I'm gonna have to rank everyone from one
through ten in terms of those things I
just said okay so on with George I would
have to give you a waiting for it a nine
oh my god out of ten I'll tell you why
because your fashion would be terrible
and I would have to look at you but I
would be like I don't look at that but
um but when I want to say in terms of
like you would get [ __ ] done like well I
would tell you to do things and you
would
I mean you would do it you're right you
right I'll give you a seven okay because
I think that you wanderlust a little bit
I do I think that you daydream I think
that you're confused right I think that
I oh I think I would I think you would
steal some rations in front of you you'd
be like yeah why because I have two kids
and I did it you would admit right but
and I think that you try to smoke things
that you shouldn't smoke that's not we
dude that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ] that
[ __ ] I'll give you seven sweetie I give
you a nine as well yeah yeah because I
think that you would fish the know is
that but you would be very difficult for
me do you complain a lot and you'd be
analytical about that like you would you
would you would say things I would have
to say in that environment I'll write
myself I would say I was a four know you
have Rhino hide foreskin you're very
hard to penetrate with an ax
whoa mm-hmm so he he has very thick like
you know how she'll have this extra
layer of blubber mm-hmm
how do you know he he's a good singer
really is that that's a face thing that
yes Thank You Gabi Gabi I'm gonna give
you a Gabi I'm gonna in mind this is my
desktop for the past year just keep that
in mind that's been my desktop I'm gonna
have to give you on Gilbert
your ego what about I think there's a
competitiveness with you and there's an
eagle reference iron absolutely right
that there's an ego iron sharpens iron
yeah sure i'ii go make Rosie go better I
would have to give you a seven your ego
ego would get in the way take away there
you go you have to take away the ego in
a zombie apocalypse I do you what the
[ __ ] the fact you you get the fish the
fence
Bobby the fence is open there's zombies
coming in and then you know you would be
like did you know you have hands - you
say that to me I know that you think I
would say yeah yeah and you're you'd
probably it's six months since I did why
are you the leader
you're the worst you would stage a coup
he would stage a coup I would stage a
coup for ya yeah I queen oh thank you
yeah Sasha I would have to based on my
knowledge of you and all the things I
would have to give you a 9 as well new
white because you seem like you would
have his energy right but your energy
the way your talk and your chill nasai
is a calmness his is just a stupidity
and a dumbness and a confused
he used yours is more analytical right
and and thinking things through and
being like I honestly think in in like
if John was like being gnarled right and
you know the defense that he didn't
build he gets pulled out of there right
and I'm like knocking trying to get it
and that you would be you would be like
more like it's okay I just got to figure
it out we I have all the toilet paper
here see yeah yeah I went to the store
already on my paper that's true and I
think that you would be very analytical
I think you two would be good together
yes right I think I would have to give
you eventually the mantel
I would probably one day six months it
doesn't matter you're a woman either one
I would go you know you're you guys are
both running it he will never have it I
don't need it you won't get it to close
I have my own village your your [ __ ]
betray what is the tough guy
I know but the [ __ ] can't be like you
kiss at 7.58 I know I Johnny are you
offended no no see that's why that's why
I can say whatever to this guy he'll
just giggle it off yeah
but how about a nice round of applause
for Sasha for everybody huh great job
great job
hey guys thanks for listening to episode
238 with the one and only sasha grey I
hope you enjoyed it